building a personal brand and growing an
audience is the single best asset you
can have as an entrepreneur because once
you build a solid audience and a brand
where people can know like and trust you
now you can literally make money doing
anything you're like I can create a
course I can have an affiliate program
huge facts and YouTube's one of the big
opportunities to do that the ways to
monetize that there's 10 20 30 different
ways that can follow you over the years
and you're just being so smart to
position yourself now once my business
is bigger then I'd start the YouTube
channel I would actually say starting a
YouTube channel could be one of the keys
to get in your business bigger